let me just add for the record that I'm
sitting next to Sam closer than I've
ever sat to him except once before in my
life and that his sincerity in talking
about those fears is very apparent
um physically in a way that just doesn't
communicate on the television screen
that communicates from here
Professor Marcus if you could be
specific
this is your shot man
talking plain English and tell me what
if any rules we ought to implement and
at least don't just use Concepts I'm
looking for specificity number one a
safety review like we use with the FDA
prior to widespread deployment if you
can introduce something to 100 million
people somebody has to have their
eyeballs on it there you go okay that's
a good one number sure I agree with it
but that's a good one what else you
didn't ask for three that you would
agree with number two
a Nimble monitoring agency to follow
what's going on not just pre-review but
also post as things are out there in the
world with authority to call things back
which we've discussed today and number
three would be funding geared towards
things like AI Constitution AI that can
reason about what it's doing I would not
leave things entirely to current
technology which I think is poor at
behaving in ethical fashion and behaving
in honest fashion and so I would have
funding to try to basically focus on AI
Safety Research that term has a lot of
complications in my field there's both
safety let's say short term and long
term and I think we need to look at both
I'm interested in this talk about an
agency and you know maybe that would
work although
having seen how agencies work in this
government they usually get captured by
the interests that they're supposed to
regulate they usually get controlled by
the people who they're supposed to be
watching I mean that's just been our
history for 100 years maybe this agency
would be different I have a little
different idea why don't we just let
people sue you
why don't we just make you liable in
court I mean please forgive my ignorance
can't can't people sue us
yes well you're not protection by
protected by section 230 but there's not
currently a I don't think a federal
right of action private right of action
that says that if you are harmed by
generative AI technology we will
guarantee you the ability to get into
court oh well I think there's like a lot
of other laws where if you know
technology harms you uh there's
standards that we could be stood under
unless I'm really misunderstanding how
things work uh if the question is are
more are computer laws about the
specifics of this technology and
consumer protection is a good thing I
would say definitely yes
the laws that we have today were
designed long before we had artificial
intelligence and I do not think they
give us enough coverage uh the plan that
you propose I think is a hypothetical
would certainly make a lot of lawyers
wealthy but I think it would be too slow
to affect a lot of the things that we
care about and there are gaps in the law
for example we don't really wait you
think it'd be slower than Congress
yes I do
really litigation can take a decade or
more oh I think the threat of litigation
is a powerful tool how do you give this
International Authority
the authority to regulate in a fair way
for all entities involved in AI I think
that's probably over my pay grade I
would like to see it happen and I think
it may be inevitable that we push there
I mean I think the politics behind it
are obviously complicated I'm really
heartened by the degree to which this
room is bipartisan and supporting the
same things and that makes me feel like
it might be possible I I would like to
see the United States take leadership in
such organization it has to involve the
whole world and not just the US to work
properly so I just watched a senate
meeting with Sam Altman from open II and
Professor Gary Marcus and also a very
senior lady from IBM
and I it was surreal honestly
um they were talking about the
regulatory landscape of AI in the US and
I couldn't believe the candid nature of
it I couldn't believe how open Sam
outman was about some of the potential
risks of the technology there's a
fundamental distinction between
reproducing content and generating
content
yeah but you you would like liability
where people are armed absolutely
this hearing is on the oversight of
artificial intelligence the first in a
series of hearings intended to write the
rules
of AI our goal is to demystify and hold
accountable
those new technologies to avoid some of
the mistakes of the past
too often
we have seen what happens when
technology outpaces regulation
the unbridled exploitation of personal
data the proliferation of disinformation
and the deepening of societal
inequalities
we have seen how algorithmic biases can
perpetuate discrimination
and Prejudice
and how the lack of transparency can
undermine public Trust
this is not the future we want
if you were listening from home you
might have thought that voice was mine
and the words
from me but in fact that voice was not
mine the words were not mine
and the audio was an AI voice cloning
software trained on my floor speeches
the remarks were written by Chad gbt
when it was asked
how
I would open this hearing
and the senators were saying
historically in the U.S
um companies have tried their hardest to
avoid regulation and it's almost like
they were asking for regulation but in
particular they were asking for
precision regulation I think what's
happening today in this hearing room is
historic
I can't recall when we've had people
representing
large corporations or private sector
entities come before us and plead with
us to regulate them
in fact many people in the Senate base
their careers on the opposite
that the economy will Thrive if
Government gets the hell out of the way
and what I'm hearing instead today is
that stop me before I innovate again a
message there's quite a lot of
discussion about the Facebook situation
they use this section 230 law which is
that they are not responsible for the
people on their platform generating
harmful information very similar to how
you can have a billboard company and you
can't hold them responsible for the
information that their customers are
publishing would you be qualified if we
promulgated those rules to administer
those rules I love my current job
cool are there people out there that
would be quiet we'd be happy to send you
recommendations for people out there yes
okay
you make a lot of money do you I make no
I'm paid enough for health insurance I
have no equity in open AI really yeah
that's interesting you need a lawyer you
need a lawyer or an agent I I'm doing
this because I love it so this is
particularly interesting timing because
at the end of last week we discovered at
the new proposed regulations from the EU
on the AI act it's pretty chilling
actually they could potentially this is
going to come into power in 2026 and
it's still just a proposal but it could
potentially ban American companies like
open Ai and Google from providing API
access to generative AI models and
impose massive fines for non-compliance
the ACT also targets open source
developers and software Distributors
such as GitHub the move threatens to
sanction significant parts of the
American Tech ecosystem and could create
conflicts between us and and EU laws the
ACT has extra territory or jurisdiction
allowing third parties to sue National
governments to enforce fines and the ax
Provisions are complicated including
expensive risk-taking vague risk
definitions stringent reviews and large
fines the ACT also targets API
restrictions which could cause
Anti-Trust issues for American companies
as well as open source Provisions which
could lead to conflicts with
Distributors and developers and critics
argue that this new AI act could
encourage unsafe Ai and it could create
many more problems than it solves the
ACT favors narrowly tailored systems
which have been shown to be dangerous in
the past and could lead to a situation
where only the elite have access to
Advanced AI Technologies one of the core
problems with this act is that it
designates these Foundation models in
the highest risk category and a big part
of that is because of their open-ended
nature you know they could be used to
generate anything and actually a big
theme here in terms of risk is the
ability for users themselves to create
harmful content and where does the buck
stop should you stop the users from
doing it should you hold the platforms
accountable for seeing what users are
doing on their system it's a really
really difficult problem yeah we're
claiming we need to work together to
find a totally new approach I don't
think section 230 is that even the right
framework okay so under the law it
exists today this tool you create if I'm
harmed by it can I sue you
that is beyond my areas
not for that no have you ever been sued
at all uh the your company yeah open air
gets sued huh yeah we've gotten sued
before okay and what for
um
I mean they've mostly been like pretty
frivolous things like I think happens to
any company but like the examples my
colleagues have given from artificial
intelligence that could literally ruin
our lives
can we go to the company that created
that tool and sue them is that your
understanding yeah I think there needs
to be clear responsibility by the
companies but you're not claiming any
kind of legal protection
like section 2 the 230 applies to your
industry is that correct no I don't
think we're I don't I don't think we're
saying anything my name is Sam Allman
I'm the Chief Executive Officer of open
AI
openai was founded on the belief that
artificial intelligence has the
potential to improve nearly every aspect
of Our Lives
but also that it creates serious risks
we have to work together to manage
we're here because people love this
technology we think it can be a printing
press moment we have to work together to
make it so
open AI is an unusual company and we set
it up that way because AI is an unusual
technology
we are governed by a non-profit and our
activities are driven by our mission and
our Charter
which commit us to working to ensure
that the broad distribution of the
benefits of AI and to maximizing the
safety of AI systems
we are working to build tools that one
day could help us make new discoveries
and address some of Humanity's biggest
challenges like climate change and
curing cancer
our current systems aren't yet capable
of doing these things
but it has been immensely gratifying to
watch many people around the world get
so much value from what these systems
can already do today
we love seeing people use our tools to
create to learn to be more productive
we're very optimistic that they're going
to be fantastic jobs in the future and
the current jobs can get much better
we also love seeing what developers are
doing to improve lives
for example
be my eyes used our new multimodal
technology in gpt4 to help visually
impaired individuals navigate their
environment
we believe that the benefits of the
tools we have deployed so far vastly
outweigh the risks but ensuring their
safety is vital to our work
and we make significant efforts to
ensure that safety is built into our
systems at all levels
before releasing any new system
openai conducts extensive testing
engages external experts for detailed
reviews and independent audits improves
the model's Behavior
and implements safety and monitoring
systems
before we release gpt4 our latest model
we spent over six months conducting
extensive evaluations
external red teaming and dangerous
capability testing
we are proud of the progress that we
made gpt4 is more likely to respond
helpfully and truthfully
and refuse harmful requests than any
other widely deployed model of similar
capability
however
we think that regulatory intervention by
governments will be critical to mitigate
the risks of increasingly powerful
models
for example
the US government might consider a
combination of Licensing and testing
requirements for development and release
of AI models above a threshold of
capabilities
there are several other areas I
mentioned in my written testimony where
I believe that companies like ours can
partner with governments
including ensuring that the most
powerful AI models adhere to a set of
safety requirements
facilitating processes to develop and
update safety measures and examining
opportunities for Global coordination
and as you mentioned I think it's
important that companies have their own
responsibility here no matter what
Congress does
this is a remarkable time to be working
on artificial intelligence
but as this technology advances we
understand that people are anxious about
how it could change the way we live we
are too
but we believe that we can and must work
together to identify and manage the
potential downsides so that we can all
enjoy the tremendous upsides
it is essential that powerful AI is
developed with democratic values in mind
and this means that U.S leadership is
critical
I believe that we will be able to
mitigate the risks in front of us and
really capitalize on this Technology's
potential to grow the US economy and the
worlds and I look forward to working
with you all to meet this moment I look
forward to answering your questions
thank you this is Christina Montgomery
from IBM AI is not new but it's
certainly having a moment
recent breakthroughs in generative Ai
and the Technologies dramatic surge in
the public attention has rightfully
raised serious questions at the heart of
today's hearing
what are ai's potential impacts on
society
what do we do about bias what about
misinformation misuse or harmful content
generated by AI systems
Senators these are the right questions
and I applaud you for convening today's
hearing to address them head on
well AI may be having its moment the
moment for government to play a role has
not passed us by
this period of focused public attention
onai is precisely the time to Define and
build the right guard rails to protect
people and their interests
but at its core AI is just a tool and
tools can serve different purposes
to that end IBM urges Congress to adopt
a Precision regulation approach to AI
this means establishing rules to govern
the deployment of AI in specific use
cases not regulating the technology
itself
such an approach would involve four
things
first different rules for different
risks
the strongest regulation should be
applied to use cases with the greatest
risks to people and Society
second clearly defining risks there must
be clear guidance on AI uses or
categories of AI supported activity that
are inherently high risk
this common definition is key to
enabling a clear understanding of what
regulatory requirements will apply in
different use cases and contexts
third be transparent so AI shouldn't be
hidden consumers should know when
they're interacting with an AI system
and that they have recourse to engage
with a real person should they so desire
no person anywhere should be tricked
into interacting with an AI system
and finally showing the impact for
higher risk use cases companies should
be required to conduct impact
assessments that show how their systems
perform against tests for bias and other
ways that they could potentially impact
the public and to a test that they've
done so
by following risk-based use
case-specific Approach at the core of
precision regulation Congress can
mitigate the potential risks of AI
without hindering innovation
but businesses also play a critical role
in ensuring the responsible deployment
of AI
companies active in developing or using
AI must have strong internal governance
including among other things designating
a lead AI ethics official responsible
for an organization's trustworthy AI
strategy
standing up an Ethics board or a similar
function as a centralized Clearinghouse
for research resources to help guide
implementation of that strategy
IBM has taken both of these steps and we
continue calling on our industry peers
to follow suit
our AI ethics board plays a critical
role in overseeing internal AI
governance processes creating reasonable
guard rails to ensure we introduce
technology into the world in a
responsible and safe manner
it provides centralized governance and
accountability while still being
flexible enough to support decentralized
initiatives across IBM's Global
operations
we do this because we recognize that
Society grants our license to operate
and with AI the stakes are simply too
high we must build not undermine the
public Trust
the era of AI cannot be another era of
move fast and break things
but we don't have to slam the brakes on
Innovation either these systems are
within our control today as are the
solutions
what we need at this pivotal moment is
clear reasonable policy and sound guard
rails these guardrails should be matched
with meaningful steps by the business
Community to do their part
Congress and the business Community must
work together to get this right the
American people deserve no less
today's meeting is historic I'm
profoundly grateful to be here I come as
a scientist someone who's founded AI
companies and is someone who genuinely
loves AI but who is increasingly worried
there are benefits but we don't yet know
whether they will outweigh the risks
fundamentally these new systems are
going to be destabilizing they can and
will create persuasive lies at a scale
Humanity has never seen before Outsiders
will use them to affect our elections
insiders to manipulate our markets and
our political systems democracy itself
is threatened
chat Bots will also clandestinely shape
our opinions potentially exceeding what
social media can do choices about data
sets that AI companies use will have
enormous unseen influence those who
choose the data will make the rules
shaping Society in subtle but powerful
ways
there are other risks too many stemming
from the in from the inherent
unreliability of current systems a law
professor for example was accused by a
chatbot of sexual harassment untrue and
it pointed to a Washington Post article
that didn't even exist
the more that that happens the more that
anybody can deny anything as one
prominent lawyer told me on Friday
defendants are starting to claim that
plaintiffs are making up legitimate
evidence these sorts of allegations
undermine the abilities of juries to
decide what or who to believe and
contribute to the undermining of
democracy
poor medical advice could have serious
consequences too an open source large
language model recently seems to have
played a role in a person's decision to
take their own life the large language
model asked the human if you wanted to
die why didn't you do it earlier and
then follow it up with were you thinking
of me when you overdosed without ever
referring the patient to the human
health that was obviously needed another
system rushed out and made available to
millions of children told a person
posing as a 13 year old had a lie to her
parents about a trip with a 31 year old
man
further threats continue to emerge
regularly a month after gpt4 was
released openai released chat GPT
plugins which quickly LED others to
develop something called Auto GPT with
direct access to the internet the
ability to write source code and
increased powers of automation this may
well have drastic and difficult to
predict security consequences what
criminals are going to do here is to
create counterfeit people it's hard to
even Envision the consequences of that
we have built machines that are like
Bulls in a china shop powerful Reckless
and difficult to control
we all more or less agrees on the values
we would like for our AI systems to
honor we want for example for our
systems to be transparent to protect our
privacy to be free of bias and above all
else to be safe but current systems are
not in line with these values current
systems are not transparent they do not
adequately protect our privacy and they
continue to perpetuate bias and even
their makers don't entirely understand
how they work most of all we cannot
remotely guarantee that they're safe and
hope here is not enough
the big Tech company's preferred plan
boils down to trust us but why should we
the sums of money at stake are
mind-boggling emissions drift open ai's
original mission statement proclaimed
our goal is to advance AI in the way
that most is most likely to benefit
Humanity as a whole on constrained by a
need to generate Financial return seven
years later they're largely beholden to
Microsoft embroiled in part in epic
battle of search engines that routinely
make things up and that's forced
alphabet to rush out products and
de-emphasize safety Humanity has taken a
back seat
AI is moving incredibly fast with lots
of potential but also lots of risks we
obviously need government involved and
we need the tech companies involved both
big and small but we also need
independent scientists not just so that
we scientists can have a voice but so
that we can participate directly in
addressing the problems and evaluating
Solutions and not just after products
are released but before and I'm glad
that Sam mentioned that we need tight
collaboration between independent
scientists and governments in order to
hold the company's feet to the fire
allowing independent access to the
assistant independent Sciences allowing
independent scientists access to these
systems before they are widely released
as part of a clinical trial like safety
evaluation is a vital First Step
ultimately we may need something like
CERN Global International and neutral
but focused on AI safety rather than
high energy physics we have
unprecedented opportunities here but we
are also facing a perfect storm of
corporate irresponsibility widespread
deployment lack of adequate regulation
and inherent unreliability
AI is among the most world-changing
Technologies ever already changing
things more rapidly than almost any
technology in history we acted too
slowly with social media many
unfortunate decisions got locked in with
lasting Consequence the choices we make
now will have lasting effects for
decades maybe even centuries the very
fact that we are here today in
bipartisan fashion to discuss these
matters gives me some hope this was Sam
Altman's take on the effect on the job
market like with all technological
revolutions I expect there to be
significant impact on jobs but exactly
what that impact looks like is very
difficult to predict if we went back to
the the other side of a previous
technological Revolution talking about
the jobs that exist on the other side
um you know you can go back and read
books of this it's what people said at
the time it's difficult
I believe that there will be far greater
jobs on the other side of this and the
jobs of today will get better first of
all I think it's important to understand
and think about gpt4 as a tool not a
creature which is easy to get confused
and it's a tool that people have a great
deal of control over and how they use it
uh and second gpt4 and things other
systems like it are good at doing tasks
not jobs and so you see already people
that are using
gpt4 to do their job much more
efficiently
um by helping them with tasks now gpt4
will uh I think entirely automate away
some jobs and it will create new ones
that we believe will be much better this
happens
again my understanding of the history of
technology is one long technological
Revolution not a bunch of different ones
put together but this has been
continually happening we as our quality
of life raises and as machines and tools
that we create can help us live better
lives the bar raises for what we do and
and our human ability and what we spend
our time going after uh goes after more
ambitious more satisfying projects so
there there will be an impact on jobs we
try to be very clear about that and I
think it will require
partnership between the industry and
government but mostly action by
government to figure out how we want to
mitigate that
um
but I'm very optimistic about how great
the jobs of the future will be history
is not a guarantee of the future it has
always been the case in the past that we
have had more jobs than new jobs new
professions come in as new technologies
come in I think this one's going to be
different and the real question is over
what time scale is it going to be 10
years is it going to be 100 years and I
don't think anybody knows the answer to
that question I think in the long run
so-called artificial general
intelligence really will replace a large
fraction of human jobs we're not that
close to artificial general intelligence
despite all of the media hype and so
forth I would say that what we have
right now is just small sampling of the
AI that we will build in 20 years when
we look back at the AI of today 20 years
ago we'll be like wow that stuff was
really unreliable it couldn't really do
planning which is an important technical
aspect reasoning abilities were limited
but when we get to AGI artificial
general intelligence mainly let's say
it's 50 years that really is going to
have I think profound effects on labor
should we consider independent testing
labs
to provide scorecards and nutrition
labels or the equivalent of nutrition
labels packaging that indicates to
people whether or not
the content can be trusted what the
ingredients are
yeah I I think that's a great idea these
models are getting more accurate over
time
uh you know this is this is as we have I
think said as loudly as anyone this
technology is in its early stages it
definitely still makes mistakes we find
that people users are pretty
sophisticated and understand where the
mistakes are that they need are likely
to be that they need to be responsible
for verifying what the models say that
they go off and check it
um
I I worry that as the models get better
and better uh the users can have sort of
less and less of Their Own
discriminating thought process around it
but but I think users are more capable
than we could often give them credit for
in in conversations like this I think a
lot of disclosures which if you've used
chat gbt you'll see about the
inaccuracies of the model are also
important and I'm I'm excited for a
world where companies publish with the
models information about how they behave
where the inaccuracies are and
independent agencies or companies
provide that as well I think it's a
great idea on on the subject of
nutrition labels I think we absolutely
need to do that I think that there's
some technical challenges in that
building proper nutrition labels goes
hand in hand with transparency the
biggest scientific challenge in
understanding these models is how they
generalize what do they memorize and
what new things do they do the more that
there's in the data set for example the
thing that you want to test accuracy on
the less you can get a proper read on
that so it's important first of all that
scientists be part of that process and
second that we have much greater
transparency about what actually goes
into these systems we don't know what's
in them then we don't know exactly how
well they're doing when we give
something new and we don't know how good
a benchmark that will be for something
that's entirely novel
I thought this was quite an instructive
part of the conversation uh one of the
Senators was asking Sam Altman about
what he considers to be harmful content
and she gave an interesting example and
Sam Altman replied that you should be
able to detect harmful content and also
the users of generative models should be
forced to show clearly or perhaps the
platforms as well should show clearly
that content is generated and this to me
demonstrated that he still thinks AI as
it is today shouldn't be licensed there
should just be these controls maybe on
the platform and the users and I think
that distinguishes Sam from Gary because
Gary presumably thinks that
um perhaps even models today should be
licensed and regulated what what do you
consider a harmful request one would be
about violent content another would be
about content that's encouraging
self-harm another's adult content not
that we think adult content is
inherently harmful but there's things
that could be associated with that that
we cannot reliably enough differentiate
so we refuse all of it so those are some
of the more obvious harmful kinds of of
information but in the election context
for for example I saw a picture of a
former president Trump being arrested by
NY PD and that went viral I don't know
is that considered harmful there are
things besides uh you know should this
content be generated or not that I think
are also important so that image that
you mentioned was generated I think it'd
be a great policy to say generated
images need to be made clear in all
contexts that they were generated and
you know then we still have the image
out there but it's we're at least
requiring people to say this was a
generated image some element impressed
me on this bit as well so um cynically
with regulation we quite often say that
large corporations Embrace regulation
because it kind of raises the bar and it
makes it very very difficult for
startups or competitors starting out
getting into the scene and Sam Altman
was absolutely Resolute that he does
want the Innovation the startups who
wants to maintain that fire and he was
really open about that and I was
impressed this is even more relevant
given the new EU and the AI act which
might have a chilling effect on startups
in particular trying to build these
types of large language models I think
it's super important I think there are
very different levels here and I think
it's important that any any new approach
any new law does not stop The Innovation
from happening with smaller companies
open source models researchers that are
doing work at a smaller scale uh that's
a wonderful part of this ecosystem in of
America we don't want to slow that down
there still may need to be some rules
there but I think we could draw
align at systems that need to be
licensed in a very intense way the
easiest way to do it I'm not sure if
it's the best but the easiest would be
to talk about the amount of compute that
goes into such a model so we could
divide you know we could Define a
threshold of compute and it'll have to
go it'll have to change it could go up
or down I could down as we discover more
efficient algorithms that says above
this amount of compute you are in this
regime
um what I would prefer uh it's hard to
do but I think more accurate is to
Define some capability thresholds and
say a model that can do things X Y and Z
up to all to decide that's now in this
licensing regime but models that are
less capable you know we don't want to
stop our open source Community we don't
want to stop individual researchers we
don't want to stop new startups can
proceed you know with a different frame
as you can please state which
capabilities you'd propose would
consider for the purposes of this
definition uh I would love rather than
to do that off the cuff to follow up
with your office with like well perhaps
openings opine understanding that you're
just responding uh and you're not making
law all right in the spirit of just
opinion
um I think a model that can uh persuade
manipulate influence a person's Behavior
or a person's beliefs that would be a
good threshold I think a model that
could help create novel biological
agents would be a great threshold
things like that the topic of the AI
moratorium came up and I thought the
exchange was very interesting check it
out on the issue of the moratorium
I think we need to be careful The World
Won't Wait
the rest of
the global scientific Community isn't
going to pause we have adversaries that
are moving ahead
and sticking our head in the sand is not
the answer safeguards and protections
yes
but a flat stop sign sticking our head
in the sand I noticed that an Eclectic
group of about a thousand technology and
AI leaders everybody from Andrew Yang to
Elon Musk recently called for a
six-month moratorium on any further AI
development should we pause for six
months characterization's not quite
correct I actually signed that letter
about 27 000 people signed it
um it did not call for a ban on all AI
research it only called in nor on all AI
but only on a very specific thing which
would be systems like gpt5
every other piece of research that's
ever been done it was actually
supportive or neutral about it's
specifically called for more research on
trustworthy and safe AI I'm asking for
your opinion now though
my opinion is that the moratorium that
we should focus on is actually
deployment until we have good safety
cases I don't know that we need to pause
that particular project but I do think
it's emphasis on focusing more on AI
safety on trustworthy reliable AI is
exactly right deployment means not
making it available to public yeah so my
concern is about things that are
deployed at a scale of let's say 100
million people without any external
review I think that we should think very
carefully about doing that
what about you Mr Roman do you agree
with that would you would you pause any
further development for six months or
longer uh so first of all we after we
finish training gpt4 we waited more than
six months to deploy it we are not
currently training what will be gpd5 we
don't have plans to do it in the next
six months but I think the frame of the
letter is wrong what matters is
audits red team in safety standards that
a model needs to pass before training if
we pause for six months then I'm not
really sure sure what we do then do we
pause for another six do we kind of come
up with some rules then the standards
that we have developed and that we've
used for
gpd4 deployment uh we want to build on
those but we think that's the right
direction uh not a calendar clock pause
there may be times I expect there will
be times when we find something that we
don't understand and we really do need
to take a pause but we don't see that
yet
never mind all the benefits what would
you you don't see what yeah you're
comfortable with all of the potential
ramifications from the current existing
technology I'm sorry do not see the
reasons to not train a new one for
deploying as I mentioned I think there's
all sorts of risky behavior and there's
limits we put we have to pull things
back sometimes add new ones and then we
don't see something that would stop us
from training the next model uh where
we'd be so worried that we'd create
something dangerous even in that process
let alone the deployment I would just
again emphasize there is a difference
between research which surely we need to
do to keep Pace with our foreign Rivals
and deployment at really massive scale
you know you could deploy things at a
scale of a million people or 10 million
people but not 100 million people or
billion people and if there are risks
you might find them out sooner and be
able
um to close the barn doors before the
horses leave rather than after yeah I I
just there will be no pause I mean
there's no enforcement body to force
football it's just not not going to
happen it's nice to call for it uh for
any just reasons or whatsoever but I'm
first forgiving for sounding skeptical
no is pausing this thing is crazy
I would agree I mean I don't think it's
a realistic thing in the world the
reason I personally signed the letter
was to call attention to how serious the
problems were and to emphasize spending
more of our efforts on trustworthy and
safe AI rather than just making a bigger
version of something we already know to
be unreliable another thing I found
interesting is that the Senators clearly
they've been used to interrogating Mark
Zuckerberg and they had the mindset of
social media so they kept talking about
attentional metadata and
um you know basically all of the the
harms of social media and
um Sam Altman was clear to make a
distinction that open AI is not a social
media company and the model is quite
different I first of all I think we try
to Design Systems uh that do not
maximize for engagement in fact we're so
short on gpus uh the less people use our
products the better but we're not an
Advertising based model we're not trying
to get people to use it more and more
um
and I think that's that's a different
shape than ad supported social media
second uh
these systems do have the capability to
to influence in obvious and in very
nuanced ways and I think that's
particularly important for the safety of
children but that will that will impact
all of us one of the things that we'll
do ourselves uh regulation or not but I
think a regulatory approach would be
good for also is requirements about
how the values of these systems are set
and how these systems respond to
questions that can cause influence
openai does not we're not off you know
we wouldn't have an ad-based business
model so we're not trying to build up
these profiles of our users we're not
we're not trying to get them to use it
more actually we'd love it if they use
it less because we don't have enough
gpus I just want to thank you both this
has been one of the best hearings I've
had this Congress and uh just a
testimony to you to seeing uh the
challenges and the opportunities that AI
present so I appreciate you both I want
to just jump in I think very broadly and
then I'll get a little more narrow uh
Sam you said very broadly technology has
been moving like this and we are a lot
of people have been talking about
regulation and so I use the example of
the automobile what an extraordinary uh
piece of technology I mean New York City
did not know what to do with Force
manure they were having crises forming
commissions and the automobile comes
along ends that problem but at the same
time we have tens of thousands of people
dying on highways every day we have a
missions crises and the like there are
multiple federal agencies multiple
federal agencies were created or are
specifically focused on regulating cars
um and and so this idea that this
equally transforming technology is
coming and for Congress to do nothing
which is not what anybody hears is is
calling for little or nothing is is
obviously unacceptable Mr Marcus there's
no way no way to put this genie in the
bottle globally this is It's exploding
there's there's no way to stop this
moving forward so with that
understanding what kind of encouragement
do you have as specifically as possible
to forming an agency to using current
rules and regulations I think we need to
be concerned about internet access for
these tools when they can start making
requests both of people and and internet
things is probably okay if they just do
search but as they do more intrusive
things on the internet as we Empower
these systems more by giving them
internet access I think we need to be
concerned about that and then we've
hardly talked at all about long-term
risk Sam alluded to it briefly I don't
think that's where we are right now but
as we start to approach machines that
have a larger footprint on the world
Beyond just having a conversation we
need to worry about that and think about
how we're going to regulate that and
monitor it and so forth let me just
insert there are more Genies yet to come
from more bottles some Genies are
already out but we don't have machines
that can really for example self-improve
themselves we don't really have machines
that have self-awareness and we might
not ever want to go there so there are
other Genies to be concerned about I
think we don't really understand what
self-awareness is and so it's hard to
put a date on it in terms of
self-improvement there's some modest
self-improvement in current systems but
one could imagine a lot more and that
could happen in two years it could
happen in 20 years this this bit was
remarkable I mean I love Gary obviously
but
um Gary writes an article saying that
deep learning is hitting a wall and he's
basically made a career out of
criticizing deep learning and saying
that it will never amount to anything
and here he is in front of the U.S
Senate saying that it might potentially
start self-improving uh it's just yeah
brought time to be alive uh in a sense
we've been talking about
bad guys or
um
certain Bad actors manipulating
AI to do harm manipulating people and
manipulating people but also
generative AI can manipulate the
manipulators
it it can I mean there's there's many
layers of manipulation that are possible
and I think we don't yet really
understand the consequences they're not
perfectly human-like yet but they're
good enough to fool a lot of the people
a lot of the time I certainly agree that
those are important points um I would
add that
and Professor Marcus touched on this I
would add that as we
we spend most of the time today on
current risks and I think that's
appropriate and I'm very glad we have
done it as these systems do become more
capable and I'm not sure how far away
that is but maybe not not super far I
think it's important that we also spend
time talking about how we're going to
confront those challenges real quick
um first of all you're a bit of a
unicorn when I sat down with you first
uh could you explain why non-profit in
other words you're you're you're you're
you're not looking at this and you've
even capped the VC people just really
quickly I want folks to understand that
we started as a non-profit uh really
focused on how this technology was going
to be built at the time it was very
outside the Overton window that
something like HDI was even possible
that's that's shifted a lot um we didn't
know at the time how important scale was
going to be are you ever going to do ads
or something like that
I wouldn't say never I don't think like
I think there may be people that we want
to offer services to and there's no
other model that works but I really like
having a subscription-based model I
think there will be many people that
develop models uh what's happening on
the open source Community is amazing but
there will be a relatively small number
of providers that can make models at the
at the church
um I think there is
benefits and danger to that because
we're talking about all the dangers with
AI the fewer of us that you really have
to keep a careful eye on on the absolute
like bleeding edge capabilities there's
benefits there but then I think there
needs to be enough in their will because
there's so much value that consumers
have choice that we have different ideas
there there is a real risk of a kind of
technocracy combined with oligarchy
where a small number of companies
influence people's beliefs through the
nature of these systems these systems
can subtly shape our beliefs and as
enormous influence on how we live our
lives and having a small number of
players do that with data that we don't
even know about that scares me what
these systems get aligned to
whose values what those bounds are that
that is somehow set by society as a
whole by governments as a whole and so
creating that data set the Align that
our alignment data set it could be you
know an AI Constitution whatever it is
that that has got to come very broadly
from society
so you don't want to slow down open
source efforts we still need them to
comply with things they can still you
can still cause great harm with a
smaller model but leaving the room and
the space for new ideas and new
companies uh and independent researchers
to do their work and not put in a
regulatory burden to say a company like
us could handle but a smaller one
couldn't I think that's another Peril
and it's clearly a way that regulation
has gone the other obvious Peril is
regulatory capture if we make it as
appear as if we are doing something but
it's more like green washing and nothing
really happens we just keep out the
little players because we put so much
burden that only the big players can do
it I was attorney general Connecticut
for 20 years I was a federal prosecutor
the U.S attorney most of my career has
been an enforcement
and I will tell you something you can
create 10 new agencies
but if you don't give them the resources
and I'm talking not just about dollars
I'm talking about scientific expertise
you guys will run circles around them
and it isn't just the
the models or the generative AI that
will run models around run circles
around them but it is
the scientists in your company
uh for every success story in government
regulation you can think of five
failures
that's true of the FDA
it's true of the iaea it's true of the
SEC it's through the whole alphabet list
of government agencies and I hope our
experience here will be different but
the Pandora's Box
requires more than just
the words or the concepts licensing
new agency
there's some real hard decision making
as as Montgomery has alluded to about
how to frame the rules to fit the risk
first Do no harm
make it effective make it enforceable
what specific steps you take
uh to protect privacy well one is that
we don't train on any data submitted to
our API so if you're a business customer
of ours and submit data we don't train
it at all we do retain it for 30 days
solely for the purpose of trust and
safety enforcement
um but that's different than training
and I if you use chat GPT uh you can opt
out of us training on your data you can
also delete your conversation history or
your whole account one thing that is
absolutely Paramount I think is far
greater transparency about what the
models are and what the data are that
doesn't necessarily mean everybody in
the general public has to know exactly
what's in one of these systems but I
think it means that there needs to be
some enforcement arm that can look at
these systems can look at the data can
perform tests and so forth
I really want to just explore what
happens when these companies are already
controlling so much of our lives a lot
has been written about the Fang
companies what happens when they are the
ones that are dominating this technology
as they did before corporate power
corporate concentration has in this
realm that a few companies might might
control this whole area I radically
change the shape of my own life in the
last few months and it was because of
what happened with Microsoft releasing
Sydney and it didn't go the way I
thought it would in one way it did which
as I anticipated the hallucinations and
I said that it would still be a good
tool for misinformation that it would
still have trouble with physical
reasoning psychological reasoning that
it would hallucinate and then Along Came
Sydney and the initial press reports
were quite favorable and then there was
the famous article by Kevin Roos in
which it recommended he get a divorce
and I had seen Tay and I had seen
Galactica from meta and those had been
pulled after they had problems and
Sydney clearly had had problems what I
would have done had I run Microsoft
which clearly I do not would have been
to temporarily withdraw it from the
market and they didn't and that was a
wake-up call to me and a reminder that
even if you have a company like open AI
that is a non-profit and Sam's values I
think have come clear today other people
can buy those companies and do what they
like with them and you know maybe we
have a stable set of actors now but the
amount of power that these systems have
to shape our views and our lives is
really really significant and that
doesn't even get into the risks that
someone might repurpose them
deliberately for all kinds of bad
purposes and so in the middle of
February I stopped writing much about
technical issues in AI which is most of
what I've written about for the last
decade and said I need to work on policy
this is frightening
I'm a big believer in the democratizing
potential of Technology but I've seen
the promise of that fail time and time
again uh where people say oh this is
going to have a big democratizing force
my team works on a lot of issues about
the reinforcing of of bias through
algorithms the failure to advertise
certain opportunities in certain zip
codes
um but you seem to be saying and I heard
this with web3 that this is going to be
difod decentralized Finance all these
things are going to happen
I think can be very centralized to a few
players who already control so much
so this point that I made about use of
use of the model and building on top of
it as a this is really a new platform
right people frequently comment like I
can't believe you get this much
technology for this little money uh and
so what people are the companies people
are building putting AI everywhere using
our API which does let us put safeguards
in place uh I think that's quite
exciting and I think that is how it is
being democracy not not how it's going
to be but how it is being democratized
right now
um there is a whole new Cambrian
explosion of new businesses new products
new Services happening by lots of
different companies on top of these
models one of the things that I'm most
concerned about with gpt4 is that we
don't know what it's trained on
um I guess Sam knows but the rest of us
do not and what it is trained on has
consequences anyway we're up to 58
minutes now so I'm gonna stop editing I
think I've extracted all of the most
interesting parts from the Senate
discussion it was a fascinating
discussion I hope you've enjoyed this
summary and we'll see you back very soon
cheers